time travel in Attack on Titan explained
usually when someone inherits one of the
nine Titans it's a normal thing for them
to see the past memories of other people
who had the same power however when it
comes to Holders of the attack Titan
they have the unique ability to see
memories from past users and future
users as well because of that it meant
that Grisha who had the attack Titan was
able to receive memories from the future
coming from Aaron meaning they can't
communicate through time also notice how
when Grisha saw Zeke in this scene it
was only because Aaron was standing
directly behind him looking at Zeke and
Grisha was seeing Zeke through Aaron's
eyes later in the episode Grisha saw
Zeke for a second time and once again it
was because Aaron was standing directly
behind them looking at Zeke and then
sending those memories back into the
past